30-minute workouts 20-minute recipes
10-minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hi everyone it's joanna here today's
class is a 15-minute gentle stretch
focusing on nurturing healing and
boosting the immune system
by moving and stretching in the morning
this will remove any stagnant energy
within our cells
it will help to improve relaxation and
to start our day energized
for those of you who have been inactive
and you're in the process of recovery
this workout will also be really
beneficial for you
so let's get started
each stretch will be for 45 seconds long
and this entire workout
will be very dynamic okay so let's just
flow along
let's start on the mat let's start on
all fours
so tuck your toes under hips
in line and your shoulders should be in
line with your arms
let's just start with a gentle cat and
cow stretch okay
so arch look all the way up
and now into
a cow position and slowly arch
and curl okay so
really feel the stretch on your back
and feel the energy flowing within your
body
good look as high up as you can remember
throughout the workout
do not rush okay do not rush all right
take it at your own pace and really
listen to your body
good and now slowly come up to a
standing position
the next stretch is going to be an
inchworm to upward dog
so start with your knees slightly bent
slowly
inch forward into a plank position drop
and look up feel the stretch on your
lower back and now slowly push yourself
back up
and inch back up and stretch up
reach up dive down keep your knees a
little bit bent
reach upward dog
and now slowly inch back
up you should also feel the stretch on
your hamstrings now let's challenge
yourself
keep your legs straight feel a deeper
stretch on the hamstrings
inch forward upward dog push into the
ground
and slowly come back
up all right let's dive one more time
slowly inch forward up
and stay in a plank position now let's
move into
groiners all right so step your left
feet forward
and back right foot forward
and back so alternating between your
left
and right and i want you to really feel
a deep stretch
on your hip flexor alright
back and step forward
good if this is too tough you can
release your hand
push it back down step back
push it and back
down so for those of you who has tight
hip flexors or tight lower back
this workout is really good
back into a plank step push it out
up and push
last one more back into a plank and
slowly
drop back down all right
next is going to be a side stretch okay
so start
at the edge of your mat point your left
leg
out okay right palms down
tuck under reach and
twist good so feel the stretch on your
inner thighs
and feel the stretch on your back as you
rotate up
so again all the movements are very
dynamic so keep moving keep
flowing throughout the workout okay
go under tuck your belly and
reach up good
push up keep going
remember to breathe as you
stretch okay do not hold your breath
breathe through the exercise good now
let's change the other side all right
right leg out left knee on the floor
left palm down ready toes pointer
forward
tuck and reach
up tuck and
reach good job keep going keep
reaching good
with every rep you want to stretch
deeper all right
breathe in and breathe out
feel the stretch on your right inner
thigh
point your toes
brace your core
good look up towards the ceiling
and just breathe
very good all right now
let's just slowly come back up
the next workout is going to be a chair
pose
with a twist all right so stand shoulder
width apart with a toast pointer forward
what i need to do is reach
up as you come down twist
just like a squat reach up
twist good again we're flowing
through the workout twist reach up
stretch
feel the work on your quads your
hamstrings
and your glutes up
open up your heart open up your chest
we're starting our day energize reach up
and rotate working
on your obliques as well keep going
up twist
up and twist now just
reach up okay good job all right
the next workout will require a little
bit of balance okay
it's going to be a side stretch against
then shoulder width apart
side stretch and as you come crunch
okay step down stretch really feel the
stretch on your side
up and crunch whoo all right so
final balance side and crunch
there you go reach and crunch
really ground your right foot
into the floor and look at one
focal point remember reach to the side
really feel the stretch
before you crunch okay slow
and controlled movement
to the side stretch crunch
stretch and crunch you should also feel
the stretch
on your lats good job now change side
okay this is going to be a little bit
more challenging
so reach to the side and crunch
tap crunch
reach and crunch good job really reach
breathe in and breathe out
find your balance
raise your core tuck your belly in
tighten those abdominals reach
and crunch good job keep going
and remember to breathe out as you
crunch your leg up
a few more
you should start to break
into a slight sweat as well okay
all right now let's get back down onto
the floor okay
the next workout is going to be a plank
to
a cross reach so start in a high plank
position
brace your core as you get into a
downward dog
cross and reach the opposite
angle okay again if this is too
difficult
you can reach for your knees to begin
with
good crunch and
reach so really pike your butt up
get into a high mountain position and
reach as far as you can
good job reach keep going
cross over and tap
nice okay now from a plank
let's get into a high lunge okay step
you right leg forward
get into a high lunge back down
step back left leg forward
high lunge again working on your balance
working on your core strength and the
strength
from your lower body reach up step down
alternating lunge strong legs
if this is too difficult you can rest
your knees
on the floor and push yourself back
into a plank position okay this
is an alternative step back
if not knees off the floor
strong high lunge
all right going
step back up
and now slowly push yourself
back up okay next
sumo squat with a side to side
stretch okay so step wide toes pointed
out
okay what i want to do is get into a low
sumo squat
twist up twist
so up and push okay so keep it moving
keep it flowing and really push your
knees out
feel the work on your quads feel the
stretch
on your inner thighs as well as
your back as you rotate your torso okay
try to get your shoulders to reach
towards your opposite knee
reach let's go deeper
nice come on challenge yourself push
deeper good job
shoulder to knee all right
okay remember the plank to downward dog
that we did now let's step it up
let's get back into a plank position
this time we want to reach the opposite
leg
to the opposite elbow okay so point your
leg up
reach good so kick your right leg up
right knee to your left elbow
only working on one side
okay point this is a three legged dog
knee to the opposite elbow
remember do not rush i want you to
extend
feel the full stretch and point
point good job keep flowing keep going
if at all you feel that you need to take
a short break you can always get
into a child's pose okay back
into a high plank now let's work on
the opposite side okay so left leg
pointed up crunch in
all right crunch as far in as you can
left knee to right elbow
remember to square your hips okay do not
rotate this is wrong square your hips
point good up
and point good job
reach point
keep going you are strong
can you feel that your entire body is
working together
can you feel the energy within your body
it's waking up all the cells in your
body
okay and releasing any toxins
from their body keep going keep
breathing
one more and out
okay i am
sweating and i hope you are at home as
well okay
now let's lie down on to
the mat okay the next workout is going
to be a glute
bridge much so keep your heels close
keep your butt lifted and now what i
want to do is
march alternating between left
and right so drive your knee
towards your chest press your shoulders
into the ground hold it at the top
position
and get your core and
march okay so knee towards
your chest squeeze your glutes
constantly engage your
muscles good do not drop right now
keep marching and slowly
drop back down okay
great work all right this is your final
workout okay
it's going to be an alternating leg
raises
so start with both legs pointed
reach stretch release
stretch and release so we're working on
a core
and at the same time we are also working
on your hamstrings okay
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
point your toes
breathe out as you come up and remember
don't just collapse slowly
place your body back
down up point
and up can you feel your little abs on
fire
i can up release and
up oh my gosh well done okay
take this moment to just stretch it out
extend your arms
stretch out point your toes really feel
the stretch
throughout your body very well done guys
you have done a 15 minute
gentle morning stretch to boost your
immune system and to also help you with
the recovery
all right now just bring your knees to
your chest
okay hug it tightly feel the stretch on
your
hips and now i just wanted to gently
rock
side to side okay massage
your lower back this is a really good
stretch slowly massage your lower back
okay and now slowly come back up
push yourself back up one more last
last stretch let's get into a child's
pose
forward and just stretch it out
and slowly come back
up ah very
very well done that was a quick
15-minute morning stretch
to boost your immune system and to also
help you through your recovery
i hope you feel a lot more energized and
i hope that you will start your day
feeling amazing feel free to do this
workout
every morning before you start your day
or even end your day with this workout
and don't forget to like this video let
me know how you got on in the comments
below
and do check out a lot more workout
videos on my youtube channel as well as
healthy recipes and fitness tips
if you haven't yet subscribed then go
ahead and hit the subscribe button
on my youtube channel and i will see you
next time
all the best